feel like my Jewish friends and my black
friends they putt heads a lot nowadays
over who had it worse that's a big
argument in that Community slavery of
the Holocaust got pretty heated one
night almost came to blows my black
friend had to be all right man let's
take it easy we got stuff in common too
let's focus on that right we're both
oppressed both contribute a lot to the
Arts and our grandparents are both
ashy I'm just saying Jews and black
people lot in common you know I go to my
black friend's house the closet's got a
big pile of shoes go to the Holocaust
museums a big pile you get it you get it
all right some aren't having a heard one
guy go oh these Jews huh they're acting
like babies these Jews are acting like
babies I'm like I disagree I think Jews
are tough I think they're resilient I do
however think babies are acting like
Jews yeah I was at a diner last week
with my buddy he's Jewish it was a baby
one table over they were doing the same
both were in little hats yeah bab
was all uncomfortable and squirming I
look at my friend he's like my
back then the bill came they both
their pants and
left